a ladies and gentlemen Eve chemo so I'm
excited to tell you about our new IP
from our studio in the French Alps so
studio has a lot of multiplayer
expertise you know those guys have done
Splinter Cell multiplayer they have done
also assassin's creed multiplayer and
they worked on the division on some part
of the game so for the first time we are
combining the trail of action sports
with fully explorable open world so this
game will give you a chance to challenge
your friends and to share your
adventures with the community it's a
completely new genre and I am sure you
will love it thank you
it's that moment where I've committed to
leaving but I haven't left the earth yet
nothing you could do but charge forward
what I love the most in the mountains is
that I can do anything I want it's pure
freedom you know there's always a bit of
fear you don't have a little fear you
know then your little crazy I think
nothing else matters up here all the
girls he's just going no one else around
the moment my feet leave the earth
everything else disappears got my own
monster it's pure adrenaline nobody it's
what I live for
the mountain is your canvas you know you
can paint your own picture that's what
the beauty of it is the most important
thing for me is to try something that
never been done before am I scared sure
but fear can be a tool
it can keep you for far and beyond you
think your limits are
I'm studio manager with a tech with us
and I'm creative director or ego and
also we are from Ubisoft and see at the
base of the Alps just a few miles from
the tallest peak in Europe LeMond blonde
from our studio windows we are
surrounded by the mountains and they
have inspired us to develop the game
that we are here to show you today up in
these mountains sport isn't always about
winning some time it's just about doing
awesome things with your friends and
living life to the first and sometimes
it's just about capturing those
memorable moments and sharing them with
your friends let's show some gameplay
take it away you go thank you
that's good
welcome to the world of steep a massive
open world partially set in the Alps at
the intersection of Italy Austria
Switzerland and France we're currently
flying a very greedy mobloc and in case
you're wondering agree means needles
first thing we'll do is learn on a small
rock over there and that is the man on
the right walking up to the summit it's
a ton of the player from the community
from here we can never enjoy the view
and observe the world around us the big
guy in front of you is a non bro the
biggest summit in the region and in the
distance you can see the matter own one
of the wildest cuts in the game and on
the right you've got the rav strange the
region we come from where ubisoft uncie
stands in steep we developed a really
cool observation tool we call it
mountain view mountain view allows you
to zoom out from your position observe
the world and navigate into the
environment or mountain range will be
populated by drop zones drop zones are
on three points for you to drop in the
world when you're ready now let's get
back to our initial position besides
drop zones the game we look for a wide
range of challenges for you to test your
skills the one in front of us is a
wingsuit activity and not the other
player drops in with following and
trigger as a challenge
this is a proximity flying race
challenge
we just secured the silver medal and as
we learn we could choose we could choose
a move on to the skiing in the agree but
we'd like to introduce you to another
region so let's switch to Mountain View
and editor to Aravis
the purpose of this next sequester to
show you what it's like to play online
with your friends or with other players
from the community
as your ride you will keep metal meeting
other players from the community having
fun in the mountain let's switch
opponent you for the wound riders
as you noticed the game won't support
GoPro views
all don't know them we really need to
pose here too much at the same time now
I like to show you something special if
we go back to Mountain View take a look
at that trail every line you do in the
world create a trail and that trail is
really cool if not only allows you to
check what you've done on your ride so
you can analyze your line but it also
allows you to launch a replay of what
you've seen and what you've done
you can rewind pause control the camera
go slow mo
and follow any players you've met and
the ID here is really to push that
replay of your performances or just
crushes to all social networks so you
can share it with the world even better
not only can you share videos let's say
you like that jump over the cliff you
know it's a tricky one you can push it
as a challenge to your friends you
define the rule share it so it becomes
part of the content your friends will
see in their game but let's catch up
with our red paraglider
you
there is one last being a lot to show
you steep is definitely about sharing
intense thrilling crazy or just few fun
moments and it's also about enjoying the
mountains
thank you very much thank you
we're inviting you all on to the montane
as soon as tomorrow steep will be fully
playable on the show floor if you're
watching from home please visit steve
gamecom to register for a chance to
participate in steep better phases these
game ships this December thank you very
much